we're just going to jump in and have
this conversation i want to hear the uh
the story tell us what happened so um
real quick real quick just the general
context is i think it was 2018 the story
breaks that
you the you know at the time the ceo
papa john's on a phone call
and they said in this i think it was a
forbes article right it was forbes
article came out claiming that you used
a racial slur or something and then all
of a sudden this was like a cascade of
them kicking you out of your company
they were trying to claim that you were
a racist and all these really awful
things and then the media just began to
twist everything out of proportion and
lie about what was happening now i guess
the crazy thing is
it sounds like the way you described it
like a conspiracy against you
well you got to kind of go back a little
bit in time as it was a a training call
um and we were talking about race which
is very sensitive and we were the do's
and don'ts and unbeknownst to me they
they taped the conversation and
throughout the call they they tried to
debate me when i was looking at well sir
who is oh the laundry service the ad
agency was trying to get me round up and
to say something and that was going to
hurt myself but i didn't know that at
the time that that was a it was a setup
so
um they kept that one little clip and
fortunately for me i feel like i'm the
luckiest guy in the world because they
accidentally left the tape running so as
soon as they hung up with me they kept
talking about hey we got him we're gonna
send him out really oh yeah we got the
tape we got him on tape i got a tape so
we have the truth it's always a complete
setup
they set on for about five weeks and
they said if you don't give us six
million dollars washerman and laundry
service we're going to bury the founder
and i went to the ceo and to the board
and i said hey they're trying to extort
six million dollars if we don't give
them six million dollars they said
they're going to bury the founder that's
extortion we should call the fbi
and so
that it blew up
and the company just let it happen
that's what makes me think the company
was co-conspired in this because the
company didn't do an investigation
they didn't set up a special committee
to investigate and if they would have
they would have seen there was a tape
the truth was i didn't say something
that was racist what i said was
anti-racist they changed the narrative
well we ought to issue a quick
clarification
because of the likes of people like
ibrahim x kennedy anti-racist actually
means racist and i'm not i'm not i'm not
kidding i mean it sounds funny right but
uh kendy is the i guess he's the the
progenitor of anti-racism which is an
ideology
that states
in his uh i got to be very careful how i
say this for obvious reasons i mean like
we're talking about candy says that he
wants racial discrimination so
anti-racism according to him is more
racial discrimination so that's why you
know they they they take these phrases
and try to control them and that's part
of how they they play this game so to
put it simply you're you're the ceo of
this company you're doing a regular
training phone call it was like a
sensitivity trainer or something right
exactly telling people not to be racist
to be to be excellent to each other and
the the statement you made was that you
said something about i think it was
colonel sanders
was it sanders colonel sanders was
habitual about using the m-word in a
derogatory manner and in my mind that
was a no-go that's absolutely something
a founder doesn't do so we were using
him
metaphorically as an example of what not
to do
and because you're like hey this is a
bad thing don't be like him they were
like we got him
yes they recorded you
and i didn't i didn't know that about
the uh the recording where they admitted
or they they're like yeah we got them
haha yeah when i heard they recorded the
conversation i went good because what i
said was anti-racist i knew what i said
they asked me to apologize the next week
and i said i'll apologize for the
misunderstanding i apologize for what
happened but if i apologize for saying
something that's anti-racist then that's
racist and i wasn't gonna apologize yeah
i gotta point out i said this before the
show talking about a racial slur and the
history of the word and its mechanics
and how people feel about it is
different than calling someone that word
completely different in fact you can
call someone a very nice word in a
horribly mean way and be more offensive
than talking about a slur oh yeah like
if you were talking to a woman and
you're like oh you're so beautiful
aren't you yeah you look great today
right the way you say it but here's i
got to add to that ian it wasn't it's
not just describing the word john was
actually saying it was a bad thing yeah
it was it was actually saying don't be
racist yeah but i think in life you've
got to own your own you got to take the
hit and you know we're not going to bs
your your audience there's three things
we can all agree on one is they set me
up no doubt about it it was a setup um
two is they reverse what i said i didn't
i didn't use the word draw i i quoted
cited paraphrase what somebody else says
that i would never say and three i
shouldn't have said the word
you know should not have said the word
yeah that's how they got you
yeah it's it's it's really challenging
that we're in a space now where
well let me just go back in time george
carlin
everybody loved george carlin he was a
hero on the left and he has a bit where
he goes on stage and says as many racial
slurs as he can and then actually calls
two very prominent black comedians the n
word and even i like by today's
standards i'm like wow
like that's brutal man i i'm i'm not
sure i feel about that but george carl
was making a point that just saying the
word isn't what's what's so bad about it
what's bad is it's the person behind the
word of the things they're doing with it
now i gotta i gotta admit i'm not a a
complete fan of the end of that bit from
carlin even like especially by today's
standards i'm kind of like well i don't
think that that was appropriate saying
the racial stories i understand the
issue is you got to be able to say words
to tell people what the words are you
know what i mean like it would i i think
the problem with you saying the word was
that
they were able to
manipulate that in the press
changing it from john says a word and
describes it as something you don't say
and can criticize someone for saying it
to
john used a racial slur used it as if to
imply you called someone a name
the challenge now is
there there there are instances where i
was actually was talking to somebody
we have we have people come on come on
the show all the time asking us about
censorship and what do we have to watch
out for because we know youtube is very
very bad happy
and then someone was like are we allowed
to say the n word and i was like what i
was like absolutely not are you joking
like you don't i'm not i'm not a fan of
that and they're like really i was like
even like in the context of world war ii
and i went
you mean nazi and they're like yeah yeah
because you can't say that either like
just by saying that youtube's algorithm
would probably flag this video down rank
it demonetize or whatever simply for
bringing up
a word like that and so there there were
these instances where i was talking to
people explaining to them the problem
with not being able to even describe
things anymore there is a very famous
documentary about a man named james
baldwin i cannot tell you the name of
that documentary because youtube could
ban us for simply saying the name of the
documentary and it's not using the the n
word as most people know it it's a
different n word we also can't say and
how am i supposed to describe to people
the various words that can't be said if
there's a bunch of different words that
start with the letter n
this is the problem and so when i heard
that story about you i was like well how
do you tell your employees don't say
these words when you can't actually tell
them what the word is
well i think there's no place for the
word period
the thing i like about what you're doing
on the weekend is you work on your
culture you know you're trying to change
things and and set an example and make
the world a better place
and so anything that further divides our
country anything that doesn't really
involve like kindness and thoughtfulness
and consideration and collaborative
alliances for our fellow man i think
that should just be off the table
because
um the media kind of thrives on fear
um to your point if the journalist the
media would have done what you did
all you did is do a little homework you
know you looked at
the stories and
thought about it thought about it and
you got it right i mean i i can't
believe it you're 32 years old um
you weren't where you're at today back
then and you nailed it you nailed it to
a t what happened and if um
journalists really cared about their
dignity and their integrity
i think i think the approval rating
right now networks i think 15 percent or
something oh it's a miserable is it
miserable and i think it's because
they're not honest and i think the
american people are tired of being lied
to but what i want to do with this
situation is i want to find a way to
emphasize forgiveness
pardon the unpardonable forgive the
unforgivable and let everybody know that
sometimes you're going to get a raw deal
and sometimes you're going to get kicked
in the teeth
and that's not cool especially in this
situation because the race thing is
about it's pretty pretty brutal to be
painted in that box especially on a
false narrative but if we can find a way
to for other folks to inspire them to
get through their adversity then that
would be to me that would be the bang
for a buck that i get out of going
through all this
it is
extremely challenging though i mean when
you when you have
what we're seeing in schools there it's
it's critical race applied principles
they call it critical race praxis crp we
call it applied principles because the
acronym is a little bit more uh accurate
in my opinion but you have them
you know just going to children and
they're teaching children to be racist
so yeah i mean we if it's not i agree
with what you're saying you know we want
to we want to inspire people to be kind
to be critical thinkers to improve
themselves to build a culture people
need to be responsible to a certain
degree we want to help each other but we
also have some responsibility well
what's happening now is
you try to be nice you try to be
forgiving
they take advantage of it they come
after you i mean take a look at exactly
what happened to you i mean i understand
what you're saying you know forgive the
unforgivable and or pardon the
unpardonable but
the people that you know uh i guess
conspired against you
they've learned no lesson in fact
they've enriched themselves so uh
it sounds like you mentioned this a
second ago that this ad agency i think
it was right they they were recording
you they set you up but that even within
your own company there were people who
are seem to be seem to be working
against you
yeah we had a couple board members um
steve ritchie was the ceo who was
getting ready to get terminated so you
know he had to be part of this to set me
up because he was going to get uh so so
you weren't the ceo no it wasn't the
ceo's chairman of the board oh okay okay
i was wrong correction another gentleman
mark shapiro who was head of governance
um he wanted the marketing business and
uh after he knew that as long as i was
chairman of the board and involved that
it was a conflict of interest for a
board of director to have an account the
marketing count of course when i got off
the board the first thing they did was
gave mark
shapiro the 40 million dollar
marketing deal and he got a 10 million
dollar package wow so um a complete
violation of duty of loyalty but we had
a couple of board members that
they had personal gain the company was
making uh a a lot a lot of money
and um we had a um
uh
washerman who owned laundry service they
had agency he was good friends with
roger goodell remember i'm hammering
goodell in the paper going
tell get your act roger goodell is the
commissioner of the nfl
um i'm hammering him that you know you
got to get this solved to the players in
owner's satisfaction so goodell didn't
like being called out on that so we had
we got goodell we got washerman with
laundry service
steve ritchie with papa john's and and
mark shapiro
um they set me up
the rest of the board didn't do their
due diligence they didn't do an
investigation they went along with it
and we end up um with a complete
disaster that really hurt my employees
it hurt my franchisees
very badly and it hurt my community
louisville kentucky they left my
hometown when i lost control they left
my own hometown so
i'll be fine um you know
we'll live to see another day i've got a
lot of things i'm working on i'm excited
about but a lot of good hard-working
people that wake up and woke up every
day to make papa john's great they lost
their jobs and their families got hurt
and that that's not cool you know why i
think the other board members didn't
stand up for
you they didn't want to appear in the
news to be defending someone was accused
of racism
so it wasn't about doing an
investigation it was about i'm not
sticking my neck out and get involved in
this we see what these people do when
they when they go around smashing
windows and starting fires the last
thing anyone wants to do is be on their
radar
yeah i think there was an element of
cowardness to this i think the board
members took the easy way out said okay
we'll just pin all this on john we'll
pin up our own job we'll take the lazy
way out and uh the easy way out and um
you know um and to make john the hick
guy make john the fall man that's what
they did yeah i agree with that yep but
that's okay but you know because you
don't you don't gain anywhere in life
that being the victim so you know right
they did it you know i got a two-inch
violin can we play
let's play it for three seconds and get
on with life because you know it's you
you got to figure out a way to use this
whole
i don't know if you want to call it an
episode or uh uh what a chapter in the
book whatever we got to find a way to
propel this and use this to our
advantage to make society uh better were
you freaking out when all started
happening [ __ ] i didn't i didn't know
what happened
i i treat everybody with kindness and
respect i mean i and
um
we we were raised so so good with
regards to respecting everybody
regardless of the skin color that that
was just part of our family and
um
so i knew it was bs i knew it wasn't
truthful so but i didn't understand how
it happened how do you take something
best place to work in kentucky making
160 million bucks a year we're growing
we just passed 5 000 stores and how do
you make it into this mess on a false
narrative and so i didn't really quite
understand it and then
probably two or three months after this
broke it was like you know i think they
set me up i mean really and then here it
is three years later we still can't get
documents from papa john's we're still
waiting on 13 000 documents three years
later that's how bad see we have the
setup and now we have the cover-up the
next question is who done it how far up
the food chain does this go you're
you're are you still suing finally
yeah we have a litigation right now with
laundry service casey washington laundry
service and we're waiting on 13 000
documents they've got six lawyers
between the two of them and they fought
this for eight months
and papa john's has fallen to 220 now
for two and a half years so either they
have something that's really bad or
they're stringing us out but if they
have something that that's not bad
they're sure doing a heck of a job
hiding it from us thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you